hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Willow John
chapter 17 handsome is attempting to
explain justments something that's a bit
difficult to grasp as we're gonna see as
we get further down or precisely want
the divine simplicity or if you like the
divine unity would consist in and why is
this actually a problem well in the the
two chapters just before if someone was
able to tell us quite a few things about
what God is what the divine substance is
and isn't a way different than that
other beings are so for example God is
Justice God is also just those are the
same thing for for God but human beings
are not justice human beings can only be
just by having the property or quality
of justice by by which they participate
in justice itself which is got an aunt
some ground go up a whole list of things
that got is so God is not just justice
God is also wisdom God is reason God is
eternity God is you know human II God is
lion if we could go through this entire
list and now when we think about these
these these
properties or these goods as Anselm is
going to call them do we think about
them as being the same thing now reason
and wisdom maybe we want to say those
are connected with each other but Ansel
just in in the passage earlier talked
about about human being who is just but
not wise as opposed to somebody who is
wise but not just and so presumably to
be why isn't to be just or not this same
thing because if they were then by
meeting wise I'm going to automatically
be adjusted by being just I would one
get the be wise wouldn't I so it seems
that these have to be different things
we know that they are for creative
beings it's a bit of an assumption
though to say from that that that logic
must automatically apply to the divine
substance and there's a problem with
this a problem that ants on raises among
these various attributes is the
attribute of unity now what is it to be
a unity it means to be a single thing
not to be as he's pointing out here to
be a competent of all sorts of other
things so this is going to be a real
sticking point you know we've got the
idea that there's a lot of different
divine attributes which seem to be many
good things and yet one of those
attributes is precisely unity and we can
say that simplicity is also another
divine attribute as well even the word
in another here is a bit misleading oh
isn't it as I guess a so the question is
that could God be a competent of these
various good things maybe God let's say
go along with this logic here God is
totally Justice and God is also totally
reason and got us totally life and all
these other things and yet they're all
rolled it together in this thing that
the substance that we call God it still
seems like they have to be treated as if
they're not necessarily parts like parts
of you know let's do a little bit of
illustration here these are bits of
chalk right so they all have the same
basic form they're the same kind of
thing and they're a groove so that does
not there's a sort of unity there but
it's not a very strong unity at all what
about my hand fingers right each finger
is its own entity but it's not going to
be what it is if you cut it off
Aristotle has a great example of the
hand not being a hand when cut off from
the body
it's only a hand and named because you
know it's it's ceases having its organic
operations now another way that we can
talk about it is in terms on aspects or
ways of speaking so he talks for example
here about human being some of the
things that we could sing about a human
being you know even more to the core
than say justice because not every human
being is just or wisdom since not every
human being is wise is that human beings
are or have body right that they're also
rational and that they're human and
Ansel tells us about this he says a
human being a sin to be body rational
human these three things are not said in
one way or under at the one aspect for
he is body according to one rational
according to another and neither of
these individually is the whole of the
fact that he is human very interesting
thing to say isn't it and some this is
sort of a side note but the ants alone
that you know he thinks that human
beings are rational creatures and that
that is part of what gives us our
greater degree of being and yet that
rationality is not the entire
our being isn't human is something more
than them so could it be that that God's
attributes are lined up with each other
in that way so God is just about as
rational and God is all these great
things even unity but considered under
different aspects the in some says no
well that's not going to work because
God is a supreme unity each one of these
things each one of these Goods each one
of these things that it is better to be
unqualifiedly than not to be light
justice like being light truth each of
these things are God they are what God
is so they actually are each other put
an exclamation point there I don't know
if you can see it because that was a
pretty pretty startling doctrine to say
isn't it that's that's something it
takes a bit of thinking in order to make
sense of so he says that nature is of no
mania composit in every it isn't every
way these many good things it must be
that all those things are not several
but actually one this is what divine
unity means or implies interestingly
that would mean and we'll come back to
this implication in just a moment that
divine unity is not something radically
different than saying divine goodness or
divine justice now what is the upshot of
this each of these things as Ansem says
is the same as all the others and he he
adds a extra bit to there that I didn't
put on the chalkboard
each of them is the same as all the
others whether considered individually
or singly or considered as a whole as a
totality so divine goodness is the same
thing as divine reason as divine being
as whatever we want right and it is the
same whether we think about it
individually or in terms of the totality
divine unity is the same thing as divine
reason to buying goodness now there's
some very interesting implications of
this aren't there metaphysically since
these things are what they are in God
and in God are what everything else
participates in so for example goodness
right you anselm it said that the
supreme goodness ie the divine substance
or God is the goodness in which all
other good things in some way
participate
likewise justice likewise even being
likewise unity right well this implies
for us is that because we understand
these qualities or attributes primarily
not in terms of God but in terms of
creative beings we're only getting part
of the picture although we are rational
we don't truly know what rationality is
because not only would we grasp
rationality as such we would also see
that rationality is in its very being
the same thing as being or goodness or
simplicity now that is a real difficult
concept to or realization to wrap your
head around and again some understands
that this is rather paradoxical he is
not claiming to have you know sifted
this to the very bottom but he is saying
look I provided you with an argument why
all of these seemingly many divine
attributes must in fact be a unity which
is also one of those divine attributes